PRIYANKA VERGADIA:
Welcome to "Get
Cooking in Cloud," where
we share the best recipes
to apply in your cloud kitchen.
I'm Priyanka Vergadia.
And in this episode, we will
talk about creating websites
on Google Cloud.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
If your business revenue
and customer satisfaction
depends on the availability and
scalability of your website,
then you are at the right place.
In this episode, we will present
four reference architectures
that let you scale small or go
large depending on your needs.
So let's dive in.
At a high level, there
are four different recipes
to build websites.
Depending on where
you are in your cloud
journey, your business
needs, and the maturity
of the development and
infrastructure teams,
one of these will
fit your needs.
Let's see how.
Static websites
are a good option
for sites like blogs,
where the page rarely
changes after it
has been published,
or where there isn't any
dynamically generated content.
All you need to set up a
static website on Google Cloud
is Google Cloud Storage bucket,
connect it to your domain name,
and that's it.
Pretty easy, right?
Now, as your business
starts to mature
and customers are
interested in buying things
from your website,
you might need
to generate dynamic content
and maybe enable payments.
But if your company
is still small,
maybe you want to be
able to grow your website
without worrying
about scaling it based
on the increase in demand.
In such a scenario,
we recommend that you
use Google Cloud's managed
and serverless offerings
like App Engine or
Cloud Run so you
can focus on delivering
features and let
Google worry about operating
and managing the infrastructure.
This recipe provides
a wide range
of features that make
scalability, load balancing,
logging, monitoring,
and security much easier
than if you had to build and
manage the website yourself.
For example, when
you use Cloud Run,
you can code in any
programming language,
because your application
is deployed as a container,
and Google will seamlessly
launch and scale
your application for you.
So give it a try.
Now, for websites with
higher complexity,
you probably want more
options and control
than a managed platform offers.
Whether it's configuring your
servers or virtual machines,
or if it's a need for a
specific memory, SSDs, and GPUs,
we recommend this third recipe--
Compute Engine.
Compute Engine provides a
robust computing infrastructure,
but you must choose
and configure
the platform components
that you want to use.
Well, Google ensures that
resources are available,
reliable, and easy to use, but
it's up to you to provision
and manage them.
The advantage here
is that you have
complete control of the systems
and unlimited flexibility.
The easiest way to deploy a
complete web-serving stack
on Compute Engine is by using
Google Cloud Marketplace.
With just a few
clicks, you can deploy
any of the over 100
fully realized solutions.
For a more detailed
explanation on how
to setup Compute Engine to
serve scalable and resilient
websites, stay tuned
for upcoming episodes.
Finally, for a larger business
with more developers and more
complicated problems,
we recommend
you use this fourth recipe and
containerize your applications.
You will notice that it becomes
really hard to manage feature
rollouts if the website
is one big monolith, which
makes it difficult to keep up
with the increase in demand
and pace of business.
Containerizing web applications
provides four key advantages.
First is
[? compartmentalization. ?]
As your apps design
becomes more complex,
containers are a good fit for
service-oriented architecture,
including microservices.
This supports scalability.
Second is portability.
A container has everything
it needs to run.
Your app and its dependencies
are bundled together.
This facilitates the
portability and fixes the,
"it works on my machine" problem
that many developers have.
The third is rapid deployment.
When it's time to
deploy, your system
is built from a set of
definitions and images
so the parts can be
deployed quickly, reliably,
and automatically.
Compared to virtual
machines, containers
are typically smaller
and deploy much quicker.
Using Container to
deploy web apps on GKE
has further advantages
because one,
container orchestration
is built in, two,
Google Cloud offers
Container Registry, which
is a private storage for
container images, and three,
you can easily use the other
components of Google Cloud
Platform in your architecture.
Using this
container-based recipe
makes sense if you have
a complicated website
with multiple different
moving pieces which
are better off in separate
services for easy management.
That's all for today on
"Get Cooking in Cloud."
Whether you're a
small blogger looking
to grow your community or a
huge multiscale e-commerce site,
hopefully, you've cooked
up something great.
Join us next time,
because we will
share the recipe to host a
static website on Google Cloud.
If you would like to
see more such content,
don't forget to like and
subscribe to our channel.
[MUSIC PLAYING]